[موسيقى]
باسلحه لا مثيل لها في العالم وفق وصف
الرئيس الروسي بلادي مير بوتين تعزز قدره
القوات الروسيه ابرز تلك الاسلحه صاروخ
سرمات الذي يسميه الروسو بملك الصواريخ
يبلغ مدى سارمات بين 10,000
و18,000 كلم وهو قادر على حمل 10 رؤوس
نوويه بقدره تدميريه عاليه
[موسيقى]
الوقود السائل ويطلق من المنصات المخباه
تحت الارض صاروخ اخر اعلن رئيس الروسي
عزمه البدء باستخدامه مطلع العام المقبل
ضمن تسليح الجيش الروسي هو صاروخ السيركن
الفرض الصوتي
سرعه الصوت في تسعه اضعاف
بحري يطلب من الغواصات والسفن وقادر على
اصابه اهداف حتى مسافه الف كيلو متر سرعه
الصاروخ الهائله تمنحه ميزه تصاحب من
تتبعها او اعتراضه من انظمه اعتراض
الصواريخها اما وزير تفاعل روسيس يرجى
شويه فقال ان الثالوث النووي الروسي لديه
جاهزيه عاليه بفضل تزويد القوات باحدث
الاسلحه ويقصد تشويغو بالثالث النووي
منصات اطلاق الصواريخ النوويه سواء
الارضيه المكشوفه منها والمخبائه والبحريه
من غواصات وسفن والجويه عبر القاذفات
الاستراتيجيه والطائرات كما اعلنت شويغو
اطلاق المركبه الفضائيه السادسه كوبل
وتعني القبه وهي تتيح مراقبه مستمره
للمناطق المحتمل استهدافها بالصواريخ في
النصف الشمالي من الارض
[موسيقى]